Tony wrote the book on WebGL literally
WebGL up and running in another one
coming coming soon he will actually will
be raffling off a couple of those books
and you can get them signed by Adam and
himself so big round of applause for
Tony great thank you Peter thank you for
Vanessa for organizing many thanks to
our hosts Google and all the sponsors as
Peter said I'm Tony Parisi I run the SF
WebGL Meetup a quick little bit about me
you don't have to feverishly write this
down these slides will be on SlideShare
and we'll post the link later so I've
been doing 3d visualization for the web
kind of as long as that's been around
coming on 20 years now I have to say
originally working at a technology
called VRML which many of you might have
heard of some of you might have played
with in middle school a few of you might
have even built something in and on and
off for the last coming on two decades I
have been building the experiences in 3d
on the web with whatever technology was
available at the time so I got very
excited in around 2009 when I heard this
thing WebGL was coming out and after
about of year of trepidation and and not
wanting to get too deep in into it I
sort of finally jumped into it year
after that I wrote a book for O'Reilly
WebGL up and running I've actually
written a second book which is an
intermediate level book the first one's
introductory it's called programming 3d
applications in html5 and WebGL that's
going to be out another month or so
right now you can get the pre-release
online Safari online through Amazon etc
enough of a plug and I do all this stuff
and I consult and I have a little
startup in the city that's building 3d
technology on top of WebGL and so with
that we live in a 3d world people move
and they think and they experience in
three dimensions these days a lot of our
media is 3d as well though most of the
time we experience it on a flat screen
right but the games we play the movies
we watch even if you remember
- I don't know 2008 election the
broadcast media we see with Wolf Blitzer
stumbling around a virtual set awkwardly
this has become a sort of a staple of
broadcast media now this is all done
with 3d graphics which has been done on
computers for many many decades
historically it's been with high-end
dedicated hardware and very expensive
proprietary software well not anymore
now the soft the the hardware you use to
render 3d runs on this phone it runs on
this desktop it runs on this Kindle Fire
HDX it runs everywhere 3d accelerated
hardware is everywhere and powers these
real-time 3d experiences we're going to
talk about today more importantly the
software to create and experience this
stuff is not only accessible everywhere
it's free it's called a web browser
see if they have audio to have audio on
the presentation okay so this is a
hundred thousand stars this was a piece
that was developed by the Google Data
arts team last year it's been around for
close to a year now
but to me it illustrates the strength of
html5 has a platform and WebGL which is
what we're going to talk about tonight
now if you look at this you'll see that
I'm interacting in real time with a 3d
presentation that is running in my
Chrome browser and I can click on a link
and it's going to zoom me into the Sun I
don't know what this is going oh it's
this little rectangle that is craziness
is that my a-v I'm going to try that
again
[Music]
all right so you see this virtual
fly-through of our Milky Way galaxy so
imagine trying to build this five years
ago would build this title you would
distribute it on a cd-rom or DVD right
people would maybe go into Best Buy or
ordered on Amazon and if you built this
the data for it would have to be
licensed he I don't know what that tile
is really do skip this data for that
would have to be licensed and if you
wanted to update it you'd have to go get
another CD we're just gonna let this
play it's like a little bit of that pile
but now it's running in a web browser
now don't know if you noticed but when I
clicked on one of those links I'm gonna
try one more time as I'm brave there we
go
that's great from Wikipedia so we didn't
have to go get that stuff from
Britannica or anything like that so the
world is our encyclopedia this
encyclopedia Galactica that's we built
was all built on html5 this is now a
rich media platform and that's what
we're going to talk about today
[Music]
back to our PowerPoint and so I don't
know who's seen this so that was a nice
visualization application but what we're
gonna see here I'm gonna bring up the
Firefox for this one because it runs us
screamingly fast and hopefully it's in
the browser cache kind of big content
this is an epic games unreal game that
was converted from their C++ code base
including an embedded programming
language interpreter it was actually
cross compiled using a technology called
M scripting compiled to JavaScript and
running in your web browser we are now
live with a full unreal game level in
JavaScript rendered in WebGL
i waz d around a little bit use the
keyboard to navigate use the arrow keys
to kind of change my camera control I'll
just go into autopilot here so if you
see me driving and futzing around but
look at this benchmarking we're getting
30fps and that's wouldn't get higher
than that I think that's probably
because of the displace thinking and
everything else but you know fast
machine you get 60 frames a second
running in your browser and that's
probably about 20 Meg's of content
coming in to download that level that
was a full epic level I mean we're
talking triple a game stuff running in
her browser
and that is all because we have WebGL
what is WebGL it's the 3d API standard
for the web
it's OpenGL ES do people know what that
is that is the software API that runs on
this phone and it runs on embedded
systems small devices that's what the es
stands for embedded systems you program
to it using JavaScript it shipped pretty
much everywhere after initial reluctance
by Microsoft they've included it in
Internet Explorer it runs on the Kindle
Fire HDX like a bandit I can show you
this stuff later beautiful device seven
inches of pure happiness running 60
frames a second 3d I love this thing and
supported everywhere except mobile
safari but there are solutions are
actually building html5 WebGL
applications I'll talk about them
shortly for iOS but on Android you can
use a browser or you can build a web app
Kindle web app and on and on the list
goes on and in fact it's coming soon to
a Bang & Olufsen TV powered by opera how
about that on your TV too so how does it
work it's an API it is not a tag said
it's not CSS you don't put a little you
know angle bracket and take cube and see
a cube on the screen that'd be nice
maybe that that will happen someday
so it's sort of like canvas drawing if
you is everyone done 2d canvas API
drawing you're quite familiar with it
it's like that but different at the same
time it's a low-level thing we're gonna
talk about in a minute so no Dom you got
to deal with that stuff yourself just
like with canvas when you want to deal
with picking you have to kind of make
that stuff up as you go or use some
tools and I'm going to show you those
and there's no way to there's no file
format built in you know if you I've
seen so many people ask questions online
about how do I see my obj files or my
other 3d models in WebGL well it's a bit
of a modeling error because WebGL itself
doesn't support those the browser
doesn't know how to load a a 3d file
natively and just show it to you you
have to write code but thankfully you
can and thankfully you can do it in
JavaScript and it runs fast so we're
going to quickly go through the anatomy
of a simple WebGL program breeze through
it because there's a lot of details to
it we don't have time for but the basic
idea
as you create a canvas element on your
page just like you would for 2d drawing
but then you get a 3d drawing context
where you get that 2d context you get a
3d context you create a viewport which
basically says the size of the rectangle
to draw into and then from there it gets
a little weird and we're gonna go
through it alright so this is the kind
of code if you're familiar with it for
you get a canvas element somewhere we
pass that into this function and it
calls get context and it says can I have
a WebGL context older browsers you have
to say experimental - WebGL but
generally this is supported now WebGL if
you don't succeed at that you probably
don't have WebGL support and put up some
kind of friendly message for your user
or do something else to fall back and
then you initialize the viewport in this
case what I'm doing is I'm gonna draw
out of the whole window then you have to
create buffers of data to represent your
3d objects arrays of numbers in
JavaScript that you then turn into this
special new thing called a typed array
which you may have heard of at this
point this is a binary data that's very
compact runs very fast it was introduced
into browsers a few years ago largely
because of WebGL and that means your 3d
data which can be very rich is stored
very compactly and you can operate it on
it quickly the other thing you have to
do which is a little new if you're a web
programmer is you have to create things
called programmable shaders if you're if
you've know OpenGL ES already you're
familiar with this you have to write
code in another programming language
called opengl SL which is for shader
language and it looks like C sort of so
if you proceed programmer you'll be kind
of familiar with it and then there are
some built-ins if you look here it knows
about matrices and vectors and 3d
thingies already because what happens is
that language gets compiled and these
compiled instructions actually get sent
to the graphics card and they're
executed on every vertex that's rendered
on the screen every pixel it's render on
the screen and the hardware just does it
super fast this kind of technology came
out of Pixar back in the day
high-end renderings now brought to every
machine on the planet that's a little
weird though a little strange to deal
with but we're going to talk about how
we can avoid that and then we get into
some real weeds here which is you got to
do a lot of low-level stuff GL itself
the ape
gie is kind of a state machine so you
say okay that buffer I created earlier
I'm gonna set it and then I'm gonna draw
with it until we go through and we do
that way we clear this is every frame
you know you're doing a
requestanimationframe kind of draw loop
we clear the canvas we set up a shader
we those buffers we created before we
set them up we have to pass matrices in
to move our objects around all this sort
of complicated stuff right so you may be
wondering at this point how am I gonna
do this really seriously well if you are
a game programmer your graphics
programmer you probably familiar with
how to do that level of opengl coding
you're good to go what you'll do is
you'll build your own engine for your
project most people though won't do that
and the good news is you don't have to
because WebGL is an open standard
because javascript is fast enough people
have written a whole bunch of libraries
now that can actually talk to WebGL and
make things easier for you and we're
gonna see some of those libraries in
action in a second for me one of the
presenters tonight goo has actually got
a great engine with a creation tool that
comes along with it so you not only have
an engine but you can build with it but
there's a long list and you know you go
online and you can get these resources
for me or other people about you know
where to start in your creation process
you know unless you're a glutton for
punishment or you really really want to
get to the low level you're probably not
going to do this stuff I showed you a
second ago you're gonna use one of these
engines and tool kits and one of the
ones I'm going to talk to you about now
is called free dot yes who's heard a
three-edged as you use it on everyday
good everybody that's great so all that
punk we saw before the five eight pages
of code is about 300 lines if I counted
we'd get it onto a page now and we're
now working with objects that if you've
got any familiarity with 3d graphics or
you can kind of get up the learning
curve fast they're the kind of objects
you'd think about it's a cube it's a
camera that's got a position in space
it's a light that's going to cast onto
the object and you see some shading here
right so that's the kind of stuff you're
probably going to the level you're
probably going to work at and the kind
of stuff you're going to be doing most
days right 3GS is really cool too
because it's got a canvas renderer an
SVG render or css3 render it is a great
engine I personally use it for my
projects and then I built a framework on
top of it to make that development
easier because what 3gs doesn't do is a
lot of high-level behavior stuff picking
and other things you kind of have to do
some groundwork so I've added a layer
but this one is pretty great and some
amazing things have been built within
the past they'll quickly show you this
one right here which is a the 360 car
visualizer it's called go so this stuff
some browser cache ah to load pretty
fast but even with the clear cache it
loads pretty quickly and we have a
beautiful interactive model with a
real-time shadow and this is great I
mean wonderful all right I got a 3d
model here I can spin it around that's
excellent but what's most excellent
about this is I mean I can really
configure this thing this is an
interactive application I'm going to
switch to another model I'm gonna change
colors right what what online car
configurator would be complete without
being able select your colors right so
amazing and I that there's a lot of
polygon detail on this thing right and a
lot of beautiful shadows in there and
the lights are baked into the scene is
this this stuff here so that's that's
part of the texture map the bitmap on
the floor but everything else is being
done in real time including with shadows
oh yes let's go back to canary I'm going
to show one more demo of something
fairly amazing this one was also done by
the Google arts team data arts team
completely different from that was
prosaic right we had a real-world
physical object we were showing this
one's about data this is about looking
at the small arms trade around the globe
for the last two decades now kind of a
sobering thought but it's very
interesting so I can actually slide
these sliders and go to different
periods of time look at the progression
of the arms trade I can look at just
imports or just exports I can actually
zoom into detail on a certain country
like the Russian Federation and see what
how they've been deal in the last few
decades and this was all built on an
open-source google globe project as well
so you could go take the data from this
or the code from this presentation but
your own data in let's say you wanted to
look at the epidemiology of has helped
me what's that virus going around right
now everyone's freaking out about
h1n1 Thank You fright if you can see the
epidemiology around the planet of that
so this is the kind of experience we're
talking about WebGL being able to power
but it goes beyond just you know
creating the models there's all this
amazing animation stuff you can do with
it - you can do morphs and skins
real-time characters and how do you do
that that's a good question I asked
myself how do I make content for this
the state of the art right now is a
little bit like we've moved from the
stone tools Age of creation to the
Bronze Age we're getting there the tools
are coming you're gonna see co-create
tonight that's a step in the right
direction what people are doing today in
these projects I showed you are they're
exporting a single model an obj file or
an STL file or one of these 3d formats
that's been around for a long time and
then they're hand
animating it their hands laying it out
they're putting the lights and you know
you basically like your model are
sitting in one room and he's like Steve
yeah you know I put the light over here
and he's talking to the program and he's
typing the things in a text editor again
well that's changing that's changing
there is a format that was pretty rich
and popular for a while called colada
that took all the data to the animations
the scenes the lights full hierarchy all
this stuff and got into these big fat
XML files and we've been using that to
show some really sophisticated WebGL
lately but the problem is they're big
fat XML files they don't load fast and
they're not tuned up for WebGL so
there's another cool thing coming which
I'm involved in firstly and we're gonna
see a lightning talk from one of the
creators of later which is called gltf
the GL transmission format so imagine
that same kind of rich data being able
to fully get into your browser real
quick because they're the all the vertex
data isn't typed arrays only the stuff
that makes sense to have in JSON or you
know high-level data is in there and
let's see if I got a link to this puppy
here love to show you this real quick as
my last demo yes so so on the load
screen the six megabyte model loaded in
about 0.4 seconds now that's what we
need if any of y'all are into the web
performance stuff and you you know go to
Steve suitors talks right what do we
know we know a web page has to load in
less than two seconds end to end right I
mean
a long time and you need to you know see
stuff on the screen a lot more quickly
than that well with these kind of
formats we can do it and this isn't of
course just a movie I can switch the
cameras here right and so these were
these this came 3d studio max was
converted to colada exported to colada
and then we ran a converter on it that
Fabrice is going to speak later his
written which takes the colada and turns
it into gltf nice and compact so that
pipeline is starting to come so all the
professional tools you know 3d studio
max Maya blender Sketchup they will be
able to support this kind of experience
see if I just go out to the free camera
for a second here you can see our little
virtual city and its full glory so there
we go so helps coming on the pipeline
well we talked about this earlier where
does it run well it runs pretty much
everywhere I did mention a little bump
in the road with iOS for whatever reason
Apple has not turned on WebGL support
inside Mobile Safari however they do
have it running in a limited fashion in
their ions platform so if you make a
Naiad to be inserted into someone's
frame iam game or whatever you've got
fully html5 that you can use to build
the ion and includes WebGL but that's
kind of limited it'd be really nice if
you could hit any website with mobile
safari in the WebGL would just work and
it's a little frustrating that hasn't
happened yet Tim Cook if you're
listening
let's talk I'll come to I'll even come
down to Cupertino I don't mind driving
down there so hopefully that will be
fixed at some point it's not yet but the
good news is there are our solutions
today that will let you take your html5
app because I know people here in this
group especially are interested in
building their stuff once an html5 and
then getting it to run everywhere you
can take your html5 app and sort of
Allah PhoneGap there are adapter
technologies for making the whole thing
run inside android and iOS platforms
that don't support WebGL yeah Android
less of an issue now because most of the
Android devices actually do it and one
I'm talking about here is cocoon Jas the
cocoon folks in the room somewhere I
know they're kicking around it's a
company called blue dye they are into
infants
Disko and they make a technology that
basically implements the WebGL API and a
color a couple of other api's that
aren't built into iOS or easy to use in
iOS and they give you some tools for
making that all easy and basically with
very little change to your code you can
adapt that and bring it into iOS and
make an app they'll even make the app
for you
hey you're not an iOS coder they'll
build it they get a cloud service doing
it for you all you have to do is sign it
with your developer ID and submit it to
the store so that's really great I
encourage you to go look at that so you
know getting really close here so my
opinion and this is why I'm so happy
we're here tonight and Peter thank you
again and Don Olmstead thank you for
suggesting I come here and talk tonight
I think we're getting to a tipping point
a year ago Microsoft WebGL I don't know
security whatever blah blah blah well
they changed their tune and they're
really supporting WebGL pretty well I
went into Best Buy
I went up to a laptop I hit a URL I knew
you know was a WebGL URL with Internet
Explorer I didn't go to Nick lead
download Chrome like I usually do on
every machine I go to at Best Buy
I just went to hit it and it worked I
hit that hundred thousand stars I hit
that car all those things I showed you
they all just worked so that's great I
mentioned the Kindle Fire HDX I know if
we're gonna get this on camera yeah yeah
here we go so here's a little
interactive piece I built for my book I
don't know if you can see it from here
cars spinning around I took this
untouched and just worked out of the box
this thing I built in html5 and WebGL
and then I had a touch event so I can
zoom and touch on different pieces of
the model that took me half a day to add
the touch support good to go running
it's 60 frames a second to some screams
amazing yeah so seven-inch great deal go
get one and then we have another speaker
tonight Don Olmstead I just mentioned he
works at Sony no you know what he did
he built the entire ps4 interface in
WebGL so there we go
four plus million seats in one whack
WebGL powered god bless you
the people who track sort of browser
stats this is a good one you know that
NORAD
a website the track Santa's progress
around the globe every year so they've
had a WebGL thing for the last couple
years and we saw 146 percent increase in
people who got into the 3d experience
which meant their browser actually
supported WebGL mostly was the issue
right
I mentioned this opera is now powering a
bang & olufsen TV with their devices SDK
so we can have Smart TVs with full html5
in them and tonight's event
I think we've broken all the records
right so WebGL definitely about the tip
the scales and I'm personally delighted
I think this is really exciting I mean
people's enthusiasm for this has been
just incredible this event tonight so I
encourage you to stay in touch all my
particulars are here like I said the
slideshow is going to be up on
SlideShare for you see if you know all
the URLs will be there and I was just
talking to Vanessa and I think what I'm
gonna do is ask oh right that you get me
a promo code so anybody from this meetup
tonight can get a free version of the
new book as an e-book print one you got
to pay for oh and I'll sign it
promise so you know we'll make sure that
we get you the new book but if you go on
Amazon search for my name you'll see
these two titles up there and with that
thank you again Peter and go forth
[Applause]